d'enfants pour l'homme kanye cela a
enlevé un enfant il a créé cet homme
incroyablement tonique c'est pas très
curieuse
le pam est témoin numéro un du rap les
petits cris liberté donc moi on a
retrouvé son corps hier soir dans la
chambre d'hôtel de pratiquants révol
indignation les mots ne sont pas assez
forts pour qualifier une émotion devant
le geste et la personnalité un homme qui
a pu nous mener les antennes de nous
faire un procès parce que nous
qualifions même que divers pour l'avoir
été une première fois entendu par les
gendarmes
je plains sincèrement il pas et puis il
ya les questions encontre de la police à
bord quand l'enfant est il mort avant la
levée du black out qui est d'accord
entre de la faire avant l'intervention
maladroite auprès de la téléphonie
on avait localisé au rami il attendait
son normale au terme d'une attente de
trois semaines dramatique mais en tout
cas pour les enquêteurs c'est faux cette
nuit par après la station il avait déjà
des attitudes et opinions
seul
la cdac son mari sans passer par ce tout
premier à la tâche dans cette chambre
qui se déroulait la soutenable pendentif
l'enfant mort sans doute depuis le début
de la fin
patrick henry qui va et vient dans la
vie d'abord témoin et puis
ce soir patrick henry annonce une
semaine et puis un jour les revenus il a
suivi ce chemin avec l'enfant kalou on
ne sait pas encore les preuves de la
culpabilité sont accablantes
mais pour les circonstances c'était sur
tout a été préparé réfléchi
patrick henry a lâché du logeur même
changer les roues de la force et à
monsieur du matin rue d'affaires est de
taille moyenne je vais dire au point de
vue caractères apparents du comportement
est clair c'est qu'il a commis des
atrocités penser qu'il est fou
totalement vous allez qualifiez folie
mais l'annoncé n'a pas fait mon ami
appartement partie le doubs mais quand
on a su remonter le temps du début
viennent quand la sanction
alors pour vous donner une idée de
l'ambiance en croit un seul monde les
condamnations aujourd'hui châtiment
exemplaire peine de mort tanimations la
retrouvés jusque sur le perron de
l'elysée ce matin près de nous souhaiter
que la justice rude évite les autres
ministres des pages en et henley a même
enchaîné en évoquant le problème de la
peine de mort surtout pas
ces déclarations contraires ont consisté
à dire que quand des crimes odieux pour
des criminels que j'appelle calculateur
qui met en balance le profil c'est ce
qu'ont de leur crime et la peine dix ans
la peine ne vais pas être légères et la
peine la plus lourde prévue par la loi
c'est la paix l'inspection financement
d'une extrême importance car blahblah
lutte pour le droit rien bien sûr les
comptes de cette masse imposante qui a
seul pu faire basculer la fragile
stabilité aux éléments des forces qui
tirent à elle ce moment la chine donc à
hue et à dia et nul ne sait où il veut
aller
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on sent mené les
bills journal du coq le
nous le répète aujourd'hui legear ici la
motta finalistes qui seront les plans
alors il sait plus ce que vous voyez en
page de droite
qu est ce qui est nouveau c'est
l'extraordinaire publicité est une façon
générale d'ailleurs ce qui sera fait que
ce pays se trouve à la critique
intérieur extérieur par exemple personne
de t'imaginer nom que l'on rapporte en
france il ya simplement un an dans une
situation semblable
aucune équipe de télévision occidentales
ne plus filmer des kinois lisant des
journaux murs aux participants même
passivement à ce que nous sommes tentés
de définir comme une nouvelle niche aux
cultures
cette nouvelle révolution culturelle ce
grave conflit idéologique
cette nouvelle crise intérieure peu
importe définition mauvais tournant
l'at-il line ciel
si oui il est en train de faire faire
aux dirigeants et au peuple chinois
l'ultime répétition générale avant sa
disparition dans cette gigantesque
épreuve de force de plans sont en
prenant d'abord elles sont accusées d'
engager la chine dans la foi de
capitalisme remis en question très
sérieusement pendant la région naturelle
il croit quant à lui que les impératifs
de la production passent avant ceux de
la révolution estime démocratie n'est
pas respectée la croissance économique
n'est pas elle qui opine et avant tout
pour l'efficacité c'est surtout ce que
lui reprochent ses adversaires une
affiche a même été vu à shanghai le
qualifiant de nouveau
quel chinois et c'est à shanghai comme
par hasard cette farouche de cause à
leur tête le non moins connu par nice et
toulon se destiner pendant un show
culturel
cet ancien ouvrier d'une quarantaine
d'années représente aile radicale d'arc
cette dernière lutte contre
l'embourgeoisement de partie des quatre
prix j'en ai pour exprimer son point de
vue dans le noir dispose de moyens
importants en septembre dans les
organisations de masse mais c'est
également bien représentés dans les
équipes rédactionnelles drapeau rouge
est du côté du peuple ce qui est
frappant
cela explique que ces journaux est
toujours soutenue des grandes campagnes
ses dernières scènes ont été tournées à
travers les jeunes cap de la révolution
culturelle
je faisais des coproductions et fait
éclater le savoir si antoine live
sortira vainqueur qui est en train
d'engager toi ça te prend deux fois par
jour c'est précisément sa disparition
suscite en remplacement de la crue est
la nouvelle salle de la trèche bien
d'une nouvelle station qui peut penser
le champ culturel et il ya même un
contenu qui ressemble de survival une
structure essentiellement nous sommes en
présence
mais également mais je pense que tout le
fait qu'elle est tout de même devenue en
quelques années 30
groupe k avec des responsabilités
nationales au niveau de l'échangé dans
toutes les parties du monde sait que la
plus grave de ce jusque là contemporaine
le nom de l'histoire du parti en liga
social lamotte
encore une fois la crise et léger et
missionne abandonne très fort raconte
vraiment donner sa chance à faire donner
l'impression de certains santé les
premiers signes de la maladie est
revenue le gouvernement et j'espère que
ça ne permet pas la voir c'est
aujourd'hui rien ne va plus et les
autres hier l'embauché est à nouveau
peur
enfin le conflit qui opposait depuis
plusieurs mois je ne sois maire à son
conseil d'administration
que lui reprochez pas d'abord il nous
laisse gestion l'accumulation de stocks
qui a failli mettre l'entreprise
l'afrique il a réussi à obtenir de
l'état une aide financière importante
cette aide qui a d'ailleurs pris acte et
puis internet ont su cultiver l'image
d'un patron d'hublot partisans de la
concertation et est il réellement
en tout cas cette image avait inquiété
les uns irrité les autres tout ce qui
limite autorités de gestion de chaque
entreprise débouché sur un échec
cela fait maintenant les syndicats leur
attitude était clair attendre et voir
nuremberg c'est l'avenir de notre ca
nous apparaît pas très sain patronat et
les travailleurs
la cgt reste totale avec la mine
association efforts afin de l'enrichir
mais c'est un peu la crise il faut écrit
les experts prévithal de la ville de
mille habitants
sur tout mais aujourd'hui c'est un peu
la dégringolade est appliqué pour milan
san remo et cette dernière est nôtre
aujourd'hui une troisième
beaucoup d'habitants la ville cent vingt
mille salariés de la chaussure qui se
retrouvent à sochaux grave ça fait du
bruit à fougères trois entreprises en
liquidation ou sur le point de l'être
la plus importante creo 650 ouvriers qui
peut coûter 24
la cfdt majoritaire veut conserver son
outil de travail quarantaine de
personnes travaillent à la prochaine
collection
les autres veille sur le score de 20
milles perdus en france à part les
intentions du social clan et pas épouser
en public par l'interaction italienne
important que ce que nous voulons et
c'est notre combat faire en sorte qu'ils
puissent se développer la création
sur 9000 salariés a ouvert trois mille
sont dans la chaussure
alors on tente des eaux a été
l'entreprise de pointe intéressant des
travailleurs concertation bon chiffre
d'affaires côté tati la production va
passer de chenil à 200 tas de chaussures
par jour pourquoi nous sud américaine
parce que les industriels clés des
succursales à l'étranger la main
d'oeuvre et préfère lorsque la
conjoncture est moins bonne
il faudrait peut-être reconvertir une
partie le monde patronal
les municipalités qui l'est c'est vrai
que la rivalité l ocm d'été n'a pas
toujours profité à l'action syndicale
c'est également vrai que les industriels
jouent chacun leur carte et que monsieur
pointa le maire pense surtout à l'europe
et à l'énorme marché aux bestiaux de
sougères sans aucune adultes et 2
transformations entre parents et le
reste
l'électronique la petite mécanique l
habillement devront dernier là aussi il
ya du chômage
la chambre de commerce et d appels et
l'or sont des terrains des bâtiments des
primes les personnes devient
s'installèrent
une priorité ce qu'il faudrait c'est
2000 emplois créés tout de suite
personne n'y croit même la lutte des
syndicats semblent assez résigné il ya
eu beaucoup de promesses
la bretagne doit dater youri terre il
faudrait que la seule fois que ce soit
le résultat d'une volonté politique
claire sinon sur la disparition
économique se souvient plus vraiment la
dictature n'a pas vraiment la liberté
voilà ce que notre les spéciales
s'il plaît une preuve des contradictions
de la doua défini qui rêve aujourd'hui
de la fenière mois manifestation voyez
des policiers mais ceux qui manifestent
s'attendre est le même que les pompiers
on n'avait jamais vu ça en espagne alors
que juan carlos ghosn a qu'une
mais ce pagne née du temps à réapprendre
la liberté syndicale
aujourd'hui après coup cela bon comme ça
je m'attendais bien un truc qui ont été
renvoyés de chez pioneer ya quelques
agents de la cantine un collège
religieux dans la banlieue matin une
réunion nous veillons à visage découvert
une situation qui leur était impossible
de cheminée il ya trois communes aurait
été dangereux et responsable vous
montrer les visages de ceux qui disent
aujourd'hui ce qui touche les spectacles
de la rue à barcelone a changé ce qui
hier était interdite les transformer
l'espagne entrée dans le tri des idées
du verbe événements il appelle habitats
tueur mais aujourd'hui ce n'est ni me je
leur ai dit qu'il est contre la
réquisition est décidée pour certaines
équipes
celui ci l'espagne va pas faire la
démocratie comme ça mais les dirigeants
que nous voulons ajoutons voisins c'est
plus de pc peu moins d'heures de travail
et une meilleure répartition des gains
restant lui nous construirons notre
avenir sur d'autres panneaux surgira
dalibard premier des ministres espagnol
tendu pour sacha mot d'ordre lancé par
le premier gouvernement de franck cardon
la presse afin d'actionner politique est
revenu il en sort parce qu'ils sont à
leur phase on reste sur la défense
qui sont ils ces projets sont encore
médias sur l'espace je sais pas car on
donne aujourd'hui porte sur le revers de
la veste le thème rouge de la
militarisation ils sont réquisitionnés
devrait être jugée devant la caméra
les réserves de la rue dans laquelle
partisans du régime défunt et ses deux
ouvertures sur fine et premier choix
soit confirmée par exemple par le
discours programme du premier ministre
c'est que l'espagne devait d'afrique à
témoins a misé sur les champs de
l'espagnol le discours du premier
ministre allaient être considéré comme
un véritable tout malgré les promesses
élections municipales en novembre 76 et
les [ __ ] alors que les milieux de
madrid
car le paradoxe et d'incertitudes de
cette nouvelle espèce
le changement est évoqué exception faite
aujourd'hui pour la loi anti ferrari
vient d'être abrogée supprimant du coup
la juridiction
choummaly fut expéditive qui permettait
de faire jugé par un tribunal militaire
tout auteur de gallipoli revanche la
loire est la même pour ce qui est de
l'organisation sanitaire avec à sa tête
le préambule rappelle que l'unité la
totalité et la hiérarchie sont les trois
branches mais son application reste
fragile
pour la première fois et ouvrier
défendent bien eu lieu
je suis tenu des grèves de 50 jours
comme ici à getafe dans la moline autour
desquels le syndicat officiel a été
dépassé par une base qui protestaient
contre le blocage des salaires
la plupart d'entre eux les mini
qu'aucune organisation de la vie
la camionnette deux gardes civils
n'étaient pas dans la culture d'heures
sup l'inra pas de sens s'est établie
entre langue et la rue des consignes ont
été données et la police intervienne du
mieux possible
eh bien je sois dans le centre de madrid
oui s'ils attaquent la police espagnole
a c'est toujours aussi intolérant les
voitures de la police
tu ne retrouves à cuzac amiens
le fil du rasoir
l'espagne joue dans des positions
délicates les rebelles une européenne
comme le zoo sans renoncer à ce que
frontonnais l'arrivée nique à la peur du
gendarme
aussi quand au classement
aujourd'hui degrés ailleurs
alternance de nuages et des glaces le
cac est ce soir du rendez vous avec une
information le premier à 20h30 avec le
roi lion avec près de 4 du deuxième but